elle est dangereuse ça fait dix ans je
le rêvais est parti
l'autre facteur 10 ans en août et c'est
vrai que il ya eu toute une polémique
autour de autour de sa mort notamment
dans sa relation familiale et son père
nous a fait de la télé confession c'est
avec vous forian oui ça fait on a parlé
dans un instant mais c'est vrai que la
relation entre jean luc et son père au
début ça se passait plutôt pas trop mal
je crois qu'il ya des on a des sms ou
s'explique où il parle assez assez
cordialement tout va bien voilà enfin à
la fin à la voilà alors je vois pas bien
mais bon j'ai sur mon fils donc c'est
plutôt bon on s'en bat pas peux-tu me
rendre visite demain en fin d'après midi
donc tout ça est plutôt plus tôt plutôt
sympathique et ensuite très vite le ton
va changer il ya d'autres sms notez
communiqué
voilà comment vas-tu aujourd'hui ceux-ci
sont pas passés tu quand tu sors jouets
etc et évidemment il ya pas de réponse
et puis après ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué à tel point que il ya une une
de gala jean luc delarue pourquoi il
détestait ses parents ça fait un peu la
conclusion la conclusion de toute cette
affaire a beaucoup marqué ce conclusion
que jean luc delarue a lui-même mis sur
la table ça c'est une génération 2 jean
luc delarue était fait d'accord voulait
bien connu oui isabelle
c'est vrai que on se demande pourquoi
dix ans après il ya encore autant de
ressentis pourquoi dix ans après il ya
encore autant de non dits pourquoi dix
ans après ils se rapprochent semble-t-il
un peu avec du retard de son fils les
eaux ne sais quoi c'est l'argent 1 c'est
la gestion c'est quoi votre avis il ya
une histoire familiale compliquée dès le
départ il leur raconte très très bien
dans son livre moi je ne saurais trop
conseiller aux gens de lire le livre de
jean luc qui dit tout de cette espèce
d'histoire familiale très très compliqué
se vouent sec lepers en est nommément et
nominalement pris à des gens comme moi
en étant persuadé que je détestais qu'on
monte jean-luc eux contre lui alors là
évidemment pas c'est une histoire qui ne
nous regarde pas un laurent mais en
revanche c'est vrai que les problèmes
entre eux est était réelle quand le père
dit c'est la faute de untel untel ou
untel non c'était vraiment entre eux et
jean luc a beaucoup souffert des
relations avec 100 alors on va écouter
le premier extrait de ses tabous café
café florian c'est au sujet de sa
disparation regardez écoutez plutôt géré
son mariage si vous après il m'a rappelé
en me disant je suis revenu en urgence à
l'hôpital parce que ça va mal et donc
est ce que tu peux passer naturellement
jeu s'est passé et puis il était ans
était entendu que je viendrais tous les
pratiquement tous les jours de voir sauf
que je n'ai jamais pu me recontacter
depuis cette date je vais envoyer des
messages ou kylie répandait sauf que
c'était pas lui j'aurais dû comprendre
ce qui se passait quand j'ai eu le
dernier message car je lui disais tu
sais que ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
entendu la voix je voudrait l'entendre
il m'a répondu non le téléphone marche
mal dont j'ai compris effectivement que
il n'avait jamais eu mes messages parce
qu'il me remerciait il m'a dit pourquoi
ne veux pas tu pas toujours téléphoner
alors qui est la personne qui avait pris
le contrôle de son téléphone mais il est
clair que les personnes qui étaient sans
arrêt sur place c'est-à-dire la future
veuve et puis également monsieur arnaud
gachy doivent savoir qu'ils avaient
accès à son téléphone moi je souffre
naturellement d'avoir été tenu à l'écart
et ce qui est le plus dur pour moi c'est
penser que mon fils a pu penser que
j'avais abandonné c'est ça c'est quelque
chose que je n'oublierai jamais ce que
montanier jamais su alors là on a
clairement l'impression qu'il était mis
de côté qui d'ailleurs écarté par année
ça qui était là
de la rue à new york mais qui était l'un
des patrons de
celui qui a dirigé réservoir ensuite à
la mort de jean luc est l'exécuteur
testamentaire théorie du père de jean
luc delarue c'est en clair et qui
n'arrête pas de dire depuis dix ans
absolument les ans on a le droit au
témoignage du père de jean luc delarue
qui a 80 balais pour expliquer à quel
point son fils a été manipulé il dit
qu'en fait la roseraie cette nana anissa
en 2008 en vrai dire être ensemble 2011
et que embellissez il a été mis sous
cocon britney spears un peu mis sous
tutelle qu'on le commercialise la tp
sous emprise en solitaire si on leur ait
converti à l'islam que c'est pas lui qui
répondait à ces sms que tout ce qu'il
faisait en termes testamentaire
notamment vous savez qu'il a partagé la
beauté de sa fortune 11 million à son
fils et 11 millions annie alice a donc
sa dernière messe que parfois il parle
de la relation qu'il avait avant jamais
cette histoire ait jamais ce que c'est
quand même connu moi j'ai chauffé au gaz
ans qui a travaillé avec mais bien sûr
dans très longtemps il m'a dit que la
pire hantise de jean luc delarue s'était
qu'on l'appelle jean claude et aucun cas
à faisait à cette erreur là et la paix
jean claude il pétait littéralement
câble ce qu'il est bien d'éviter ça de
ce qui vient un réel problème avec six
ans il encore 5 milliards et compliquée
des débuts là où je ne peux pas suivre
je comprends ça c'est leur histoire en
revanche là où je trouve le père
profondément malhonnête mais je trouve
je dis je trouve c'est que honnêtement
moi j'ai bien vu anissa et j'ai bien vu
arnaud qui était et qui reste un de mes
meilleurs amis et je les ai vus mais
pleurer auprès du lit de jean luc et
dire mais vraiment moi combien de fois
sa tombe et arnaud aux césars et renommé
disant finalement je pourrais pas venir
ça va pas jean-luc je ne peux pas
laisser les talents et laurent pleurant
pleurant donc quand l'autre billes avait
abus de faiblesse ils ont profité de lui
moi j'affirme que c'est totalement faux
et si jean-luc c'est ce vrai s'il a mené
son combat contre la drogue et tous
étaient des années ça et elle a su à
nissan lui a dit moi je ne veux te veux
pas dans ces conditions là je veux un
homme qui reprend sa vie en main et si
elle n'avait pas été là jean luc se
serait jamais sortie de la drogue donc
ce truc il avait calé dès le père dix
ans plus tôt et grâce à ce que c'est que
cette baie de fort cette relation parce
que il n'a pas été ni informé ni invité
pour les obsèques selon lui les c'est
selon on va écouter on va écouter
l'extrait audio en parle avec lorient
juste après je n'ai pas formé de
l'enterrement de mon fils j'aurais dû
l'être bien sûr et j'aurais dû avoir la
possibilité de venir lui dire du 10
radio une dernière fois comment ça peut
se faire ça c'est un enterrement qui a
eu lieu à cimetière parisien de thiais
il s'assécher en catimini sans que je
sois informé il a fallu que des amis à
moi face une véritable enquête quasi
policière bien fallu que je fasse en
sorte que des amis à moi je vienne 30 du
photo dans le cimetière de thiais donc
effectivement je pense qu'à un moment ou
un autre quelqu'un m'a parlé oui on
s'est selon lui sain alors arnaud
c'est quand même terrible d'en arriver à
ces situations à ça que le pardon ne va
même pas après après le décès oui oui
parce que là isabelle lorand des gens
qui ont connu jean luc delarue qui ont
peut-être un regard différent sur la
question jean claude delarue les
interviews depuis une dizaine d'années
depuis la rue depuis la disparition de
de jean-luc il ya quand même une chose
c'est que lui réclame pas d'argent donc
c'est quand même un point qu'il faut
qu'il faut qu'il faut souligner et lui
la seule chose qui réclament aujourd'hui
en fait ils réclament rien il veut juste
souligner le fait qu'on l'a écarté de
son fils à un moment crucial de sa vie
et quelles que soient les difficultés qu
il ait eue je pense avec son fils on a
tous à un moment de notre vie des
problèmes avec nos parents plus ou moins
graves ne pas pouvoir aller enterrer son
fils on peut quand même considérer que
c'est quelque chose de terrible quelles
que soient leurs rapports et d'ailleurs
il m'a expliqué qu'il voulait faire
alors chacun pense ce qu'il en veut
qu'il voulait faire voter une loi jean
luc delarue parce qu'il est persuadé il
est convaincu que son fils était sous
emprise et qu'il ne lui répondait plus
et que donc c'est les deux arnaud gachy
et ça et son épouse qui avait le
contrôle de son téléphone il apparaît
d'ailleurs assez c'est vrai qu'on peut
se poser la question d'un mariage qui a
lieu au mois de mai alors que jean luc
delarue on l'a vu sur des images à
l'époque était particulièrement affaibli
et il est parti quelques mois les prix
mais j'aimerais que non mais vous poser
la question quand on est ne serait ce
qu'un simple lecteur de presse people ou
un téléspectateur on peut se poser la
question d'heure on donne raison à ce
vieux monsieur pas du tout comme on
oublie juste de près on oublie souvent
de dire que ce type ça fait quand même
50 ans qu'ils essaient de faire de la
politique oui il a été soutenu par tous
qui l'a été qu'une faille être candidat
aux présidentielles tout ça dans l'oubli
c'est rené abric c'est un vieux prof à
la cool & condit le pauvre évidemment il
n'a pas assisté aux trucs de zombies on
oublie juste que jean luc delarue j'ai
juste pris cette petite note est
globalement 53 secondes qu'il a que
jean-luc a déclaré à rtl j'avais un
problème de fondations familiales des
parents qui n'étaient pas de vrais
parents c'est à dire des parents
ressources pour leurs enfants qui sont
là pour les aider pour les conseiller
pour la faire figure d'autorité mais
pour être derrière eux en clair jean luc
delarue a passé son temps et même
construit sa carrière parce qu'il avait
un vrai problème psychanalytique par
rapport à ça avec une mère totalement
absente il l'a pas vue pendant cinq ans
avant nourrir un salaire et un père qui
rapportent du monde et qui voyait jamais
à cames ans et dix ans après sa mort
qu'ils soient encore en train de jouer
les parents un peu effarouchés frousse
alors pourquoi il fait ça selon toi nous
paraissons amateurs c'est pourquoi
fait-il alors parce qu'il faut se poser
les bonnes questions parce que il n'ya
pas d'intérêt financier il est père il
touchera rien
il défend son petit fils il faut savoir
club la force y ont été partagés en deux
j'ai dit à leurs 11 millions 11 millions
or quand tu as une filiation tu paye
beaucoup plus de droits de succession ça
qu'en réalité aujourd'hui anissa va
toucher plus d'argent au final pas
toucher à la charge des patients touchés
que je crois donc que que le petit
garçon aux questions genre de pialat
payer les patients pour des il a fait
pratiquement 5 millions d'impôts c'est
juste oui comme tout le monde
bien sûr j'aimerais dire quelque chose
de très important mais rapidement
j'ai rejoins complètement florian
complètement c'est cette femme là elle
s'est accaparé ce matin
son père qui dit moi je crois en la
sincérité de son père je suis désolé les
connais on peut pas être encore
l'imaginer suggère l ai vécu j'ai vécu
une histoire similaire à sa non élection
de chauffe non je te jure laurent
lesgent papa de mariage et qu'on parle
de tout 8 et dans son lit de mort à
l'hôpital mettant qui avait pas deux
hilarant isabelle hénon il a vraiment
mais franchement ça discute mais sur le
mariage ma soeur de 5 ans le sourire
il a épousé on l'a protégé pour la
protéger parce qu'ils avaient été
déposés là parce qu'il savait qu'il
avait dix pas là bien sûr comme il a dit
c'est l'année la plus heureuse de ses
mains et on aime surtout qu'on ait
besoin c'est la plus heureuse de ma vie
mais je voulais absolument se rendre à
tanger un usineur mais assez bien merci
merci beaucoup et on espère que ça va
s'arranger moi je pense surtout aux
petits garçons